the worst day of a man's life is the day
he realizes women find him harmless they
are going to give everything they are
going to sacrifice relationships fun
partying you're just going to sit on the
sidelines be like I shouldn't have to do
that fine but you're going to get eaten
alive by all of the people that are
willing to do that and in that moment I
learned one of the most important pieces
of advice that I have for people and
that
is Tom thank you so much for coming back
on the iced coffee hour this means a ton
every single time I come to your house
AKA two times I am just flabbergasted I
am Gob smacked this is a it's a mansion
it's beautiful it's one of my favorite
houses I've ever seen in my entire life
it's in a great location you have this
Mansion you sold a company for a billion
you're married to the love of your life
you also have impact Theory where
millions of people on a daily basis take
your voice as gospel they worship your
opinion you're an incredibly intelligent
and accomplished person how do you keep
your ego in check that question is uh
always very interesting to me so the
punchline is that I have failed so many
times in my life that keeping my ego in
check is the world's easiest thing I
don't even have to think about that if
you are living at the edge of your
ability which I hope that people are
you're going to constantly fail at a
thing that you're trying to do now it's
exciting because it means you're
constantly pushing your abilities and
you're actually getting better but it
also means that every step feels
precarious so I don't move through the
world with precious few exceptions being
like Oh I got this it's like what am I
doing why am I walking this Razor's wire
I've already been successful but that's
just not how my mind works so I want to
see like the central question of my life
is how good can I get at the things that
matter to me and to do that you really
do have to put yourself in a position
where it's adapt or die and so if you
imagine when you're in the gym it's easy
to understand like there are just some
weights you cannot pick up and the
humility of trying to pick up a weight
and not being able to do it or trying to
pick up a weight you can't do it and
somebody else warms up with that weight
you know I'm I'm in the intellectual gym
every day of business and it's the same
thing there's some weights I pick up
that other people look at me in awe and
then I watch people warm up with a
weight that I can't move so if you are
playing hard enough humility will find
you you won't have to seek it out what
do you think the balances between
confidence and caution because you
obviously need confidence to forge
through and build such a big business
and uh you know had the willpower to
push through that so there's got to be a
balance right is it 8020 this one is
deeply personal so I think the marker of
a a real entrepreneur is that you can
tolerate an extreme amount of risk
because when I think about the amount of
risk that I played with in my life I
actually wouldn't advise other people to
do it and so the the best advice I can
give to somebody who's looking at the
entrepreneurial path and saying do I
want to go down this is if there's
anything else that you think you could
find joy in doing in life go do that
thing because stability matters like
there's a real thing to stability
stability uh the people with the
strongest home lives can take the
biggest risks so what that means is if
you have stability then you can go take
these big risks but if you're already on
this just completely unstable footing
because you're constantly betting things
in a way that makes you deeply
uncomfortable some amount of your brain
power is just on risk mitigation and all
of your fears and you're not going to be
able to be bold there's an idea in I
think it's F1 in racing where the day
you retire is the day you're no longer
willing to go for the Gap right because
when you move for that Gap to get around
another car it's usually the most
dangerous thing you're going to do on
the track that day and this is how
people get injured and killed and there
will come a point in your career where
you're no longer willing to go for that
Gap and that's when you know okay I'm
I'm not going to be able to win anymore
with that hesitancy and there is a
similar thing in entrepreneurship you
can't be Reckless though so it's the
balance for me Isn't So Much um you know
how do I make sure that I'm on Terra
Forma and take big risks the balance is
really is this risk the right risk to
take because if you're just blindly
putting it all on black or whatever over
and over and over you're just guaranteed
to lose there's no strategy but if you
have strategy then it becomes okay what
how many chips am I willing to put on
this bet to see like if we can really
get that Gap and that's going to be
hyper individual and you're going to be
wrong a lot which is why rule number one
in business is avoid a mortality event
so when I'm putting chips on the table
I'm saying okay the you try to get close
what are the odds that this succeeds
often times the odds are way against you
and so you just say okay I need to be
able to survive if this is a loss and
this is the thing about giving advice
about entrepreneurship that breaks my
heart because it's not enough to be a
good person to be kind to want to do
great things for the world you also have
to be good in that moment to know
exactly how many chips to put on the
table to be accurate in your assessment
of what the odds are that this will
actually get accomplished and then you
have to have that willingness to say
even though it seems pretty
impossible I'm going to do it anyway
knowing that I can't figure it out from
the shore I have to dive in I have to
swim I have to be out over my head
before I can actually figure out the
path and that's where most people just
are not going to be comfortable cuz in
that moment when you're out over your
head and you still haven't found the
path yet that's emotionally devastating
especially when hecklers in boats next
to you are making fun of you they're
saying what an idiot you are they're
saying I told you back on the shore that
this was going to end up just like this
now if you get in the boat you lose if
you swim back to shore you lose if you
keep pressing forward you might win but
you also might drown that's
entrepreneurship man that and then
really understanding business and this
is the thing that that I am really
trying to get across to people it's not
enough to have big balls and swim you
actually have to understand business
what's something that people need to
understand about business in our last
podcast you said that no matter what you
could fall back on making $2 to3 million
a year working for another company
teaching them what you know what are
some of those things that you know that
people should know if they want to get
into business okay so this is the hard
thing that I find with giving business
advice if if I'll give you broad advice
cuz I despise when people won't give an
answer but the reality is if you pick a
problem in your business then I can
really help you because now we have
specifics and we can start drilling into
a problem at a high level the answer is
easy but it's going to make it seem like
oh I understand the physics of progress
now I'm ready to go so the high answer
is the physics of progress there is only
one way to make progress in anything I
don't care if it's being a better parent
getting laid better relationships or
building a business it is simply I I
have a goal I know what my goal is I'm
very precise on what I'm trying to
accomplish which is where most people
fail they're super vague but you're
going to be really clear then I need to
identify the obstacle okay being able to
identify the obstacle the rarest of
humans can do that and so another trap
where people get fooled because they
think they understand the concept but
they just don't have the skill set
either because they haven't done the
Reps or their brain just doesn't work
like that and so they're never able to
actually identify what's stopping them
but a good question to ask is I know
where I am am I know where I want to be
why won't I automatically get where I
want to go there's some obstacle if you
can get that right then you're going to
come up with your best guess AKA a
hypothesis what's my hypothesis and what
I would need to do in order to overcome
that obstacle and make meaningful
progress to my goal again most people
are terrible at that first of all they
probably didn't have Clarity on where
they're trying to go then they did a
very bad job of identifying the real
obstacle that's standing between them
and where they're trying to get to and
then
the experiment that they decided to run
actually was Dumb and was never going to
overcome that obstacle anyway which they
had misidentified because they were
vague right like this is where all of
this begins to fall down but if you can
do the physics of progress well hyper
clear goal Clarity on what one of the
probably many obstacles are that stand
between you and your goal and then you
come up with a very wellth thought out
thing that you can do that's going to
help you overcome that and then you do
that now this is the real big part of
this and I hope somebody in your fan
base is actually drawing this out so
that they can visualize this okay so you
just ran the experiment of what to do to
overcome the obstacle to get to your
goal but it
failed this is like the the pit of death
that you can find all failed
entrepreneurs in here you have to be
completely willing to stare nakedly at
your inadequacies in that moment you
have to say okay all 10 fingers of
responsibility you're pointing back at
me this wasn't wasn't because of Co
lockdowns or anything like that I have
done something wrong but I don't yet
understand what it is otherwise I
wouldn't have failed in my experiment so
I'm going to look at this failure which
by the way you need to have metrics
going into the test saying I expect this
written down I expect this test to yield
this result so you don't trick yourself
did it yield that result yes or no no
okay why not it's all my fault that much
I know so now I'm going to figure out
what I could have done differently to
get the result that I actually wanted
and now I have a better informed
hypothesis of what to do the next time
this is a scientific method
recontextualized for business okay so
now I've got I'm smarter this time and
I'm going to redo my experiment which
will hopefully make more progress but
the reason people all die in that dip
where it didn't quite work the way that
they thought it was going to is they
Point all 10 fingers at the external
World they do not accept full and
complete responsibility that their life
is an exact reflection of their choices
every failing in my life every single
one of them is because I did not do the
right thing that means that I wasn't
good enough yet I wasn't not smart
enough yet whatever but it's all my
fault and people hate that people are
already typing in the comments do they
hear me say these words that that's a
dumb way to view the world whatever
whatever just telling you it's the only
way to make progress although before we
go into that we talk a lot about
business in this podcast and running a
business could be tough and if you run a
business you know that managing a bunch
of different softwares and spreadsheets
and plugins can be incredibly time
inefficient and a lot of the times it
takes a lot more effort than what it's
worth for but with today's sponsor
netsuite all you have to do is remember
these three numbers 36,000 25 and 1
36,000 because 36,000 companies have
already upgraded to netsuite and stop
doing things like typing in manual data
entry or sifting through scattered
information 25 because netsuite has
spent 25 years helping businesses drive
down their costs and one because
netsuite is an all-in one solution that
allows you to manage all of your kpis or
key performance indicators with one
efficient system net we can help reduce
mistakes that come from manual data
entry and trust me there are always
mistakes and also they'll prevent the
busy work from scaling with your
business so get a full picture of your
business and help make better decisions
faster and you can start by downloading
Net's popular kpis checklist for
absolutely free at netsuite.com again
that's nets.com to get your free kpis
checklist today netsuite.com sisted and
now at that said let's get back to the
podcast you did a video a Tom talk like
two years ago or something about a an
analysis on 650 books on success that
you had read up until that moment I want
to know first of all why did you read
650 because I feel like you could have
got like like 50 you know what I mean
there's diminishing returns between 50
and 650 I feel like by a lot and then
also what were the key takeaways of
those Ultra successful people what's
preventing people from being successful
at least with what you've learned from
those 650 books first let me separate
the uh headline of a YouTube video from
the reality so um I've probably read way
more than 650 books uh but obviously not
all on one subject and I think it's very
important for people to have a very
broad understanding of how the world
works so when we talk about the physics
of progress you have to get good at
knowing where you want to go the
obstacle standing between you that
obstacle is the world it's other people
it's what the human brain is like so if
you don't understand pschology if you
don't understand personality types if
you don't understand personas if you
don't understand economics like there
are a thousand things you might not
understand and that's going to keep you
blind and so you're going to keep doing
these really basic guesses at what is
going to allow you to LeapFrog that
obstacle and get to your ultimate goal a
give an
analogy the more words you have for
different shades of blue the more shades
of blue a person can actually see
because you're giving a category in the
brain for it to disambiguate those
different shades this is real there have
been studies on this and so when you
learn more through life experience
doesn't have to be a book and honestly
at this point I probably watch more
YouTube videos than I read books
whatever you're getting knowledge in a
condensed form where other people are
telling you hey I went through this
whole thing and here's what I took away
from it all of that reading all of that
YouTube watching is giving you different
shades of blue now when you have all of
these different elements that you can
plug these ideas into you have a much
more nuanced understanding of what's
stopping you and what the potential
options are like one thing I find with
beginning entrepreneurs where I can
really help them is just I've done so
many deals now I know options I know
things like they'll sketch out for six
months over oh do I go into this deal do
I not and I'll ask one simple question
what's your out what do you mean what's
my out what's your out do you have a
30-day out where you retain all of the
IP that you came in with they retain all
the IP that they came in with and so if
this doesn't go well you can back out at
30 days days for any reason whatsoever
get everything back that you started
with because if you have that what are
you worried about try it go into the
deal right but it's not understanding
all the different deal flows out there
so same thing with deal structure you
want to you can build something or you
can buy something for most beginning
entrepreneurs the thought of buying
something is the most terrifying thing
ever they don't understand you can
actually buy something through future
profits so this stuff starts getting
complicated but this is why I read right
I have a lot of shades of blue I
understand how to structure a deal or
how to work with an employee that
somebody else might have thought there's
nothing we can do and so you just have
so many more options on the table
because you have instead of only
learning from experience you're learning
from the experience of others and so you
can take in just an immense amount of
options hugely important so to further
the analogy I found that this whole idea
of shades of blue happens in language as
well so I'm learning Greek because my
wife is is Greek and so it's been
amazing but what I find I do is I will
take words that sound like the 30% of
the language that I actually understand
and I cram it into like oh that sounds
like this so it must be that or some
variation of that right it's a
conjugation of a word I understand and
you can really lead yourself astray with
that so I'll give you an example in
English for somebody who's never heard
English before when you say leak or lick
to them it's like
that's the same word right but we know
leak and lick are wildly different words
that mean very different things but when
you're trying to cram those two ideas
into the same thing because it's all you
understand you end up in a very misled
Place reading encountering information
talking to other people it's just
letting you learn the whole language of
life or the whole language of business
or to see those you know 52 shades of
blue so that you can really begin to
discern different patterns that other
people are going to miss the human brain
is on autopilot a lot and when it's on
autopilot it's drawing different
patterns recognizing different things
and drawing assumptions maybe unfounded
assumptions about certain things and
then it can cause a shift in beliefs to
see a belief that's subjective as
objective truth and you went on about
this I don't know if it was a Tom talk
or a podcast and you said that this can
cause a lot of Destruction in
relationships this can ruin your job
this can keep you poor
mistaking opinion for objective truth
how can a viewer or just anyone in
general recognize these beliefs that
they have are not the objective truth
and then how can they get closer to the
objective truth okay yeah this is this
is the big
one here's how you accept that it is
true that your beliefs are not
accurate the human brain bra is running
a simulation that you call your life now
I don't need you to believe that you're
actually in a computer simulation just
accept that your brain is not reporting
back objective reality it couldn't now
how do I know that so I'm looking at
your jacket it's green I'm looking at
yours it's like tan orangey Brown and
I'm just reading that as color but the
reality is that a certain number of
photons in a given wavelength of light
is reflecting off that back to my eye
now if I needed to do the calculations
of all of that to Det determine the
quality and the color of those objects
I'm going to get eaten right especially
if it's a Discerning that those are
orange stripes in the bush and not
another Leaf so we need to not see
things as they are which in the case of
vision is photons of a certain
wavelength reflecting off of an item we
instead need a very rapid interpretation
of that green blue orange whatever once
you understand and what I'm about to say
is literally true you can only detect
zero
.35% of the available electromagnetic
spectrum so what we think of as
everything right as we look at we're
seeing everything the reality is you see
less than you know a half a percent is
absolutely minuscule amount that we see
that's your brain just going all that
other stuff it's too much I don't need
it in order to survive so cool your
brain is running a simulation that is
designed to keep you alive long enough
to have kids that have kids it is not
optimized to fulfill you or to make you
happy or to make you win at the game of
Entrepreneurship just to keep you alive
long enough to have kids that have kids
okay that's its goal all right so once I
accept that my brain is reporting very
limited information and it's giving it
to me in a way that isn't accurate but
rather useful now I'm just like okay
well wait a second if my brain is
interrupting the flow of quote unquote
reality to distill it down into useful
what if it's ever wrong and if you've
ever seen an optical illusion you know
that the brain is wrong it's often wrong
and since I know you guys deal in money
man we know people make dumb decisions
when it comes to money because there's
so much emotion so the problem is when
we use the computer as the dominant
analogy for understanding the human mind
we get LED very astray because even in
the face of the loss of a loved one a
computer just keeps running will run
perfectly fine in a dysfunctional
household as it will in a happy
household doesn't matter humans are
completely the opposite we make
decisions based on emotion the emotion
comes first and then we lather
rationality on top of it and oftentimes
that rationality has nothing to do with
what's actually happening so as I look
at the brain and I think about that I'm
like wait that's me that's what I'm
doing so hold on a second I need to have
a different metric for what is true
other than emotion which is what most
people use I am angry therefore I must
have a reason to be angry therefore they
must be wrong and I must be right
otherwise I wouldn't feel like this not
true all of that is because you've been
building beliefs and values over the
course of your entire life that's
culture that's being raised and so now
you filter a action to your response
based on how it makes you feel because
we know from Neuroscience that your body
will give you the emotion first and then
your brain will justify the emotion and
people always justify it they don't go
hey I'm not going to believe this I'm
not going to trust this emotion so I
just don't trust my emotions like I'm
having an emotion it means something
it's tied to a belief or usually if
you're feeling angry it's tied to
insecurity if I'm completely honest and
so in business I have just found it does
not make sense to make decisions based
on insecurity or emotion it makes sense
to base that on what am I trying to
achieve so everything comes back to the
physics of progress what is that goal
what's the obstacle standing between me
and that goal oftentimes it's my emotion
which is why I say a lot of times people
don't understand and so now I'm going to
say how do I discern what is true and
this is where if I could just speak to
everybody on X formerly Twitter for a
second boys and girls the whole point
here has to be to figure out what is
true so you need to know what is ground
truth to even get that close you have to
understand what your North Star is so I
will say my North Star is to reduce
human suffering and increase human
flourishing which I will round to what I
call fulfillment not everybody's going
to share that North Star but that's mine
so now I'm saying okay I have a goal and
my brain is a prediction machine
so if based on my beliefs and my values
my simplified interpretation of what's
going on I should be able to make a
prediction if I do this I will get this
outcome now if I do that and I get that
outcome then my base assumptions were
correct and I'm close to ground truth
because I can predict the outcome of my
actions if I think oh here are all the
things that I believe to be true about
this situation and therefore it makes
this hypothesis and then I do the thing
and I don't get the result I expected
there is by definition something wrong
with my base assumptions now if people
will run that quick assessment and say
oh there's clearly something that I have
misunderstood about this situation which
is why I did not get the desired outcome
then they can actually make the physics
of progress work but unfortunately most
times people don't go oh there's
something wrong with the way I view the
world they say the world's out to get me
unfair business practices whatever
whatever but before we get into that if
you guys are looking to create high
quality content just like us at a very
low cost unfortunately unlike us we
strongly recommend you guys try out our
sponsor streamyard for those una aware
streamyard is a live streaming platform
that allows you to create really
highquality content with just the click
of a button all you need is a camera and
an internet connection and from there
you can stream content directly from
your browser this is also a platform
that we've personally been using now for
years and we've been incredibly happy
with them and they've worked flawlessly
they have so many features like a
multistream function where you're
allowed to stream on multiple different
websites all at the same time they also
have a whole bunch of various analytics
tools so you could help measure the
success of every single one of your live
streams and compare that across
platforms to see where you're growing
the most and guys even with all those
features we just shared they're still
completely free there is literally no
downside to trying them out you won't
lose any money we strongly recommend you
guys try it with the link Down Below in
the description and like I mentioned
earlier this is something that we've
been using for years now we've been so
happy with it the link is down below in
the description and they're a huge
supporter of the podcast so if you want
to support us support them link is down
below and now with that said let's get
back to the episode let me ask you this
because you're talking about not leading
with emotion but what about intuition
why do some people just have an
intuition that they lead with that says
this is what I should be doing because I
feel it my emotions are telling me
that's the right choice let me follow it
and it turns out successful well there
are definitely going to be times where
that works perfectly and so the question
becomes what is it about their intuition
that is serving them so your brain is a
prediction engine it is constantly
trying to learn from its environment and
say when I do this I get this result
now if you have a very strong track
record of trying a thing and getting a
very predictable result now it's like it
will come to you in the form of emotion
which at the risk of derailing your
whole podcast I would just say is
probably warrants taking a second to say
what is emotion so emotion starts in the
body not the brain read uh Lisa Feldman
Barrett's book how emotions are made so
your body will cough up an emotion the
reason it coughs up an emotion and not
an idea is that you can process data
faster and faster in the subconscious so
the subconscious is taking in data from
your gut from your skin from your blood
vessels from everything you're never
consciously aware of it but you're
getting all these signals which is why I
will say if you have anxiety it probably
starts in your gut not in your brain set
that aside just for now come back like
come back I know that one's important to
you very but we'll rock with this idea
for a second that that the body and the
mind are creating the emotion together
and so it's going to speak to you in a
form that the sub Sub Conscious can
understand and react to very quickly
which is emotion language is a far more
narrow bandwidth communication form so
you're going to get a feeling move away
from the bush do this deal whatever now
if your intuition is trained very well
then you might really be right you're
never going to be right 100% of the time
but you might really be right and it's
like hey that intuition because it is
trained is serving you well if that
intuition is poorly trained or it's
intuition built on a different Arena and
now it no longer applies to this new
Arena then you're in for a roote
Awakening you're talking about anxiety
let's come back to that it starts in the
gut wouldn't anxiety start in the brain
because you're overthinking certain
things and maybe you're thinking so many
scenarios at the same time that you this
could happen this could happen this
could happen and then you go spiral into
the worst case wouldn't it start there
yeah so it it is a two-way street so
what I would say is if you're not in a
bodily State uh where you're prone to
anxiety you can start thinking all the
negative thoughts you want and it just
never seems to catch fire whereas if you
are in a state and I know because I live
this nightmare if you're in a state
where you have just massively disrupted
your
microbiome and you're thinking negative
thoughts now again the emotion starts in
the body you're feeling off and you ask
yourself why am I feeling off and then
your brain goes oh you're feeling off
because you've got that test coming up
you're feeling off because you don't
know how you're going to make rent then
like yeah that is why I'm feeling off
and now it begins to escalate you start
thinking I really am worried about that
and then you start feeling more and more
anxious it takes two to tango but if
you've ever heard of generalized anxiety
disorder that's where people feel
anxious and they have no idea why they
have nothing to pin it to that alone
which I have experienced and it is
horrible I'll just tell you right now
I'm not thinking anything negative I'm
in the middle of something amazing I've
got no looming deadlines nothing bad is
happening there I mean I don't remember
specifically but I'm sure even on the
day when I got all my wealth which is a
story I think we talked about last time
even on that day I'm sure I had moments
where I was anxious and was like why am
I feeling anxious there's nothing bad in
my life right now bodily it's just
kicking off once I solved that problem
through diet it didn't make my anxiety
go to zero one I'm prone to anxiety my
mom is prone to anxiety so there is
certainly going to be a genetic factor
and then there is if I'm thinking about
negative things it is for sure going to
make me feel more anxious no matter what
if I have a legit legitimate thing to be
anxious about it's for sure going to
make it worse so it's not like it's only
the body but there's an accelerant a
massive accelerant when you haven't
addressed the concerns of the body what
I do because sometimes I get in this
train of Mind where I overthink
everything and I think the worst case
scenario is going to happen so what I've
learned uh I read it in a book somewhere
or someone told me to do this write down
everything that's bothering you just put
it down and usually it'll be two to five
things come back to to it in a month or
6 months and then think did any of that
ever happen or did it matter every
single time I've done that I've looked
back at him it's like it was so silly it
was so stupid I think that's a really
smart way to handle I need to keep
moving forward and so I need some sort
of what I'll call a pattern interrupt I
need a way to pattern interrupt these
negative thoughts and for me it's this
to Shall Pass right the ancient Buddhist
saying which is just unbelievably WI
eyes like that one's great and there's a
more modern version from Phil Jackson
the um coach unbelievable guy he wrote a
book called 11 Rings absolutely
fantastic I encourage anybody to read it
but he says things come together Things
Fall Apart and accepting the transience
of both good and bad emotions I think is
really useful it's like hey this really
may be as bad as I think this really may
be a problem in my life this may
actually change the course of my life
but I'll laugh again how do you get over
the fear of loss I don't think you do so
I'm not a person that I'm not trying to
get rid of the negative voice in my mind
that one it just has not seemed possible
so if you gave me a magic button and
said that I could press it I might might
though the negative voice does make me
take things seriously uh although mine
feels maybe a little more supercharged
than it needs to be but yeah I'm not
trying to get rid of that negative voice
I'm trying to leverage it as a um habit
Loop trigger so I want to get into an
empowering habit loop I need something
to remind me the thing that actually
reminds me to step into an empowering
mindset is often the negative voice
saying you're never going to win this is
bound to lose uh this is all
overwhelming whatever then you go H cool
thank you for reminding me boom you
can't stop me I can do anything I set my
mind to this is about the physics of
progress getting in that mode and just
executing and getting this done just by
shifting into that what Jordan Peterson
calls a micro person it which I think is
the right way cuz I have a weak micro
personality and then I have a strong
micro personality and at times I will
flip from one to the other what is a
micr personality so he refers to it with
an alcoholic and he says when an
alcoholic is desperate to get their next
drink they will lie they will cheat they
will steal it's like is that really them
or is that them in the grips of
alcoholism and if you can get them sober
they'll stopped acting like that I
thought oo that is so true man and so
all of us have like these micro
personalities when you're afraid when
you are feeling confident like you just
act and think in a different way it's a
whole nest of neuronal firings if I'm
honest like if I were going to reduce it
down to what's actually happening like
you're just in a different pattern of
brain firing and so all of a sudden you
feel differently and that feeling allows
you to act differently to be more bold
to take more risks or conversely you're
feeling worse which then makes you more
likely to step back to be protective to
Turtle up when you're in the wrong micr
personality for the situation you've got
to switch yourself and this is why
coaches and Generals are so powerful
because what they're able to do is move
an entire team or Army from one micr
personality Retreat fear whatever into
the other one where it's like attack
move forward and if you can shift a
group of people's micro personality
which as a CEO is a big part of your job
then you can do things that other people
think are impossible but it's not easy
we spoke with Mark Manson if you know
who that is uh much yeah that was what a
few days ago four days ago he said after
he released his book and it was a
success like the day after was one of
the worst days of his entire life he
also spoke to someone else after he'
been struggling with this like post
success sale accomplishment depression
uh who I think exited their startup and
they were extremely successful they sold
it for a bunch of money and that person
was struggling as well did you
experience something similar after you
sold Quest Nutrition where you had a
state of depression a loss of sense of
self maybe or were you just ecstatic
definitely not so I I learned that
lesson I am very glad so I went through
the same thing just not at the sale of
quest so when I was back at awareness
Technologies the first company that I
was trying to get rich with uh I was
worth on paper $2 million and I thought
okay I'm a multi-millionaire I'm
miserable my wife just pulled me aside
and said you are so unhappy that if you
don't change
it's going to ruin this marriage so I
was like w this is weird so I was like
how am I living the cliche of money
can't bu happiness so what you realize
as you pursue success at one point or
another you are going to figure it out
that the thing you really want which is
to feel good about yourself when you're
by yourself can't be touched by money
now the great irony is becoming the kind
of person that can generate that kind of
money you will earn a tremendous amount
of respect for yourself so it's really
in becoming capable of what I call the
Championship performance that matters
winning the championship ring does not
so if your whole career is about winning
the championship ring and you're not
building your self-esteem around
becoming the kind of person that can win
a championship when you finally get that
championship ring then you're going to
be like what was all this for I don't
feel differently about myself no how
could you a championship ring is never
going to make you feel differently about
yourself money is never going to make
you feel differently about yourself so
you've got to decide what do I value in
me and other people am I acting in
accordance with that every day and then
intentionally build your self-esteem and
your identity around that because no one
and I mean no one can guarantee that
you'll ever win a championship there's
so many great athletes they never won a
championship and dude the brutality of
life is they're forgotten because they
didn't win that Championship so I get it
I get why it matters and people want to
play for that and they want the world to
think that they're
extraordinary 100% And that need that
sickness is is powerful it's part of
what drives me I left Quest on a Monday
started impact theory on a Tuesday is
that mental illness is that a need for
something that I can't fill in myself
partly is it also that I want to do
something wonderful in the world that I
know better than to tie my sense of self
to success yes is it a recognition that
the only thing that's ever going to
matter is are you pursuing meaning and
purpose yes and so it it is
a cornucopia of desires competing
desires of negative things about being a
human positive things about what you
want to do as long as you're in control
of that you'll be fine as long as you
understand that you will never exit a
company for so much money that you never
need to matter to yourself or to anybody
else again just doesn't work like that
yeah I think for Mark his big thing was
that he felt like the bar had been set
So High by his success
that from a personal progress standpoint
he can never live up to that again and
that the best is behind you do you does
that ever cross your mind where you
worry about like have I peaked have I
done as much as I can does that ever
worry you it does but it isn't the thing
that I think about a lot so I would
consider that the negative voice so I
can't get that out of my head right I
don't want to live the last 30 years of
my life irrelevant unable to do what
these young whipper snappers can like
that's hard man and so for guys when I
heard this what I believe to be a truism
it really landed for me the worst day of
a man's life is the day he realizes
women find him harmless that's
terrifying when women are like oh he's
so cute because you're like a little old
man dude that's brutal that is a
brutality that comes for us all and so
in business yes do I fear that for sure
but I recognize that as the negative
voice I recognize that is the same voice
that tells me I'll never be good enough
so I know better so pattern interrupt
use that as a habit Loop trigger to
remind myself to step back into my
empowered micr personality not going to
spend time there so what I want to think
about is hey right now today what am I
doing that is not only exciting for me
and making my life better but makes the
lives of other people better and that
will inevitably change as I grow and try
different things and I'm cool with that
I've got a whole thing on phases which
we can talk about later if you want but
I think it's very important to
understand what phase of Life am I in
right now live your life for that phase
but with an acknowledgement that that
phase is temporary and so don't do
things just because on my deathbed I
will feel differently but don't be blind
to the fact that you will feel
differently on your deathbed about the
moment that you're in right now and so
there is some like hedging your bets
right so like I am very wise to make my
marriage my number one
priority business comes second
but business is a huge part of my life
even though I know when I'm on my
deathbed I'm not going to be like oh man
I'm so glad that I worked all those
hours I get that I already know that's
coming for me so I'm very thoughtful to
make sure that there is something that
is awesome about the the failure in fact
that's the right way to think about it
don't ask yourself what would I do if I
knew I couldn't fail because dos are
you're going to fail instead ask
yourself what would I do and love every
day even if I were failing and so I try
to live my life like that where I'm like
hey I'm in here I'm covered in the blood
of my enemies like I'm fighting I'm
doing the best that I can but I might
die on this battlefield and so I had
better have really believed this was
worth dying for well some of it I feel
like is you have different chapters
throughout your life and maybe when
you're younger that's the time where you
could spend all of your efforts building
a business when you're older you can't
quite do that as you could when you're
25 let's say so maybe your priorities
shift over time it's more relationship
based then over time maybe it's children
if you have children and it just can
develop over time I think that is a very
complex statement that as the
interviewer I will let you guide the
conversation but I've got a I've got a
whole thing about how to think about
meaning purpose kids
relationships um as you move forward my
advice for the average person which of
course nobody listening to your podcast
thinks they are the average person but
beware of trying to escape that the
average person should have kids the
average person should get married now I
don't have kids so I get it if people
want to discredit me on this the reason
that I say that though is all I think
about is fulfillment what is going to
fulfill you and I think that the reason
having a family is so fulfilling is
that's what nature needs nature is going
to give you the greatest rewards for
doing what it wants you to do and what
it wants you to do is survive long
enough to have kids that have kids and
so if you do that it is going to be
gratifying which is why people say oh my
God like you know I've had all this
success but the only thing that matters
to me are my kids cool so nature has
given us that um it's a very difficult
job to do well but if you understand
that its purpose is purpose itself then
I think people will be fine and you isue
that at your own risk and I say that to
myself I would love to talk about your
thoughts on hustle culture and why you
are such a big proponent of it
personally I tend to agree more with the
hustle culture that when you're in your
20s especially it's the time to grind
put everything else aside and work and
then you could take it easy if you want
to you have the choice in your 30s or
40s to you know take the foot off the
pedal what are your thoughts on that
this is a question of physics so dear
boys and girls men and women listening
to this show you have no moral
obligation to seek success I want
fulfillment for you and that has very
little to do with the pursuit of money
or worldly accolades or anything like
that but if you want to be successful
your goals will make demands and the
reality is the only way to do it is to
work long hours work hard and work smart
that's it and so you are up against the
reason I say this is physics you are up
against the second law of Thermodynamics
which says rightly that all things move
towards chaos and that the only way to
bring order to that chaos which would be
a business that actually sells
profitably the only way to bring that
kind of order is to pour energy into the
system and so I mean literally you are
going to turn sunlight which turns into
plants which animals eat and you either
eat the plants or the animals but you
really turnning sunlight you're going to
turn sunlight into cellular energy that
you are going to direct at growing a
business and so you're going to have to
pour an inhuman amount of energy into a
system where you're going up against
people like me and I'm doing everything
I can I'm building a video game right
now dude I'm doing everything I can to
crush The Souls of every other person
making a video game I want to beat them
all not most of them all of them them I
want to stand a top now of course some
percentage of the game developers out
there feel exactly the same and they
want to crush me and they want to stand
at top of the pile what are you going to
do you're going up against an army of
people like that that they want to play
this game to win man they are going to
give everything they are going to
sacrifice relationships fun partying and
what you on the outside because you
think hustle cure is you're
just going to sit on the sidelines be
like I shouldn't have to do that fine
but you're going to get eaten alive by
all of the people that are willing to do
that so it's just a question of physics
do you think someone can outsmart you if
they
work maybe more creatively or course
dude look Elon Musk is outsmarting
basically everybody in the game all of
us dude when I think about how little
I've achieved compared to what he's done
it's
Insanity it's Insanity so yeah maybe his
brain is just wired in such a way that
despite how Mal valuable half of us are
that his 50% that's hardwired is just so
badass also maybe he does work harder
than me maybe he is outworking me cool
then he's getting his Just Desserts
here's the hard truth man if you want to
play in a meritocracy and you all should
that means that you all have to accept
you might not be the Michael Jordan or
the Elon Musk of your era just is what
it is and so they're going to be people
to outplay me and I'm going to do my
best I'm going to play to the absolute
bleeding edge of my ability but remember
my self-esteem is not built around
success my self-esteem is built around
the sincere pursuit of becoming capable
of winning a championship that matters I
think hustle culture is fine for the
most part the the reason why I don't
like some aspect of it is because I feel
like it's giving this assumption that if
you grind every single day you make
crazy sacrifices relationships time
money effort energy Etc even your 20s
you could waste that away not waste but
like sacrifice that to get an ends that
is kind of like over glorified and
especially kind of like I would say put
in tandem with fulfillment like a bunch
of money a bunch of status Fame Etc will
not necessarily make you 100% fulfilled
fulfilled as you alluded to earlier and
I feel like with hustle culture they're
kind of putting that on some sort of
pedestal where like that will make you
happier that will fix all of these
underlying issues and so these people
are going into hustle culture hustling
because they're not okay at that given
moment and they think oh if I do all
these things and sacrifice all these
things I will be better which I don't
necessarily think is the case and I
think that's kind of an undertone of
hustle culture I think it's fine if
originally they are aware 100% of all of
the different avenues that they have the
sacrifices that they'll have to make in
order to get to what they actually want
rather than what they think they want
then I'm fine with that you had a
podcast with Justin Waller that I found
very interesting because he was very I
would say like obsessed with the word
choice that he wants people to have
choice and I agree with that in this
conversation we're having right here as
long as they have all the information
that they need to go down any Avenue
that they want rather than just like
people saying oh build a big business
make a bunch of money that will make you
happy it's like okay what other avenues
do you have do you have all the
information that you could possibly
Garner before actually you know
sacrificing your 20s using up all of
that effort and energy Etc yeah so what
I will say is you need to know what you
want in life and you are going to have
to pay assuming you want something Grand
you are going to have to pay a very
heavy price to get that that just is the
truth and so again going back to the
idea of hustle culture good hustle
culture bad it's just hustle culture
reality you will lose to the person who
outworks you you just will you're going
to lose the person that does all three
things they work harder smarter and
faster and of course it's a combination
like we talked about with Elon Musk he
may be so smart maybe he doesn't have to
work as hard or whatever the smartest
person working harder than anybody else
for more more hours is always going to
be the person that wins and so what I
want people to understand is what is
winning you need to figure it out now to
me it is self-evidently fulfillment that
is Nature's reward for doing the thing
that it wants you to do it's the proxy
nature only has so many levers so
raising a kid it it means something it's
purpose I mean people just talk about
that endlessly okay so the mechanism we
have is meaning and purpose doesn't have
to be on kids what are you going to
point that at can be kids that could be
an extreme ly fulfilling life but it
could also be building a business now a
lot of this God this gets so complicated
a lot of this has to do with your value
system what do you value so for me one
of the things that I value is maximizing
my skill set so that I can bend the
world to my will in order to make the
world a better place for more people in
the way that I Define it okay so now I'm
going to go out and again only value
myself for the sincere pursuit of that
not the accomplishment because I'm not a
and I know the accomplishment will
never matter I will simp simply look for
the next thing you cannot eat a meal so
satisfying you never need to eat again
so no matter how much you win you're
just going to want to win again I accept
that that is the nature of being a human
being but man if I've got somebody that
comes to me and they say I want to
achieve what you've achieved I sit them
down and I say a a very short set of
things number one do not value yourself
for accomplishment that is a Fool's
errand value yourself for sincere
Pursuit you with me yes cool moving on
to the next thing money's more powerful
than you think but it's not what you
think money will not make you feel
better about yourself so if you think
that money is going to solve that wound
between your father thinking you're a
dumbass and uh you know you achieve that
and your father's going to suddenly
respect you which is really just a proxy
for you're going to respect yourself it
won't work so whatever damage you have
you're going to have to address it money
won't do that thing but money is the
great facilitator Elon Musk is going to
colonize Mars because he has enough
money to build a rocket that's reusable
that's going to get us there without the
money he's never going to be able to
pull that off we have to accept the
realities and stop talking
about what sounds good there's an
economist named Thomas Soul who I
encourage everybody to look up he has
one of my favorite quotes he said this
20 years ago so I'll replace the number
that he used then with the real number
now the last 50 years have been marked
by exchanging what worked for what
sounds good don't do that you want to do
what works and the reality is building
your self-esteem around sincere Pursuit
will make you respect yourself busting
your ass and doing very hard things to
Garner a set of skills that allow you to
serve not only yourself but other people
will make you respect yourself
succeeding in having a ton of money will
come at an extraordinarily high price
and there are no guarantees you will
sacrifice endlessly to get there but if
you get there it will open up vistas of
opportunities that simply are not
available to other people there are ways
to harness other people's money and not
even have to do it with your own and if
you get very good at convincing people
with with money to give you money to
build something hey great that's another
path there are many ways to get where
you're trying to go I just hope that
where you're trying to go is fulfillment
in terms of fulfillment what was your
process like in deciding that you did
not want kids I know you've elaborated
on this quite a bit it's a highly
contended matter because a lot of people
feel very strongly that it's your duty
to have kids yeah to spread those lovely
jeans you know I I don't know that
they're wrong so here here's what I will
say to that if if I had an infinite
amount of years to live I would have
kids the reality is we don't have an
infinite number of years to live and I
when I see people that have kids I thank
them for their service completely
unironically the same way that I thank
people in the military because it is a
very important thing to do and somebody
has to do it and it is only because of
the service men and women that I get to
live and enjoy the free freedoms of this
country and not have to have served
myself it is only because of people that
are having parents that I'm able to live
and not have kids myself now I've
dedicated my life to helping kids so the
whole mission of impact theory is to
make sure that nobody gets to the age of
15 without encountering a growth mindset
through entertainment in the hopes with
my passions my talents that's the thing
that I think I can contribute most
meaningfully to I do think that we all
have a duty to help the Next Generation
come up strong I do think that matters
and I I would really encourage people to
embrace that idea anybody that wants to
have kids man I want to see you have
kids I think that's very important and I
will certainly thank you for your
service but at the same time people need
to choose the life path that's right for
them so why did I choose it one I never
wanted anything to distract me from my
wife two I never wanted anything other
than my wife to distract me from my
business and I had a plan through my
business to generate the meaning and
purpose that I think I think kids often
bring to somebody but I do think it is a
high-risk plan that I do not encourage
most people to pursue I think as I was
saying earlier most people should have
kids so couple things what if having
kids deepened your relationship with
your wife and what if kid having kids
also made you more relatable and gave
you insight and experiences data
information that you could then share to
more people and make an even greater
impact on impact Theory yeah it is very
possible that all of that is true we all
have to make decisions with imperfect
information and so you know this goes
back to the phases thing so in the
current phase of my life and every phase
that's led up to this when I ask myself
do I want kids the answer is always yes
but I want to not have kids more than I
want to have kids and that's always been
the conundrum so for a long time Lisa
and I were like in 18 months in 18
months in 18 months we'll have kids and
just every time we got to that 18-month
mark it was like N I still don't want
kids right now but what if you're you're
sick
right and then then you decide that you
want kids or 65 well so I'll ask an even
harder question what happens when I'm 80
and I regret not having children and I
know now that I will regret not having
children when I'm 80 barring some uh
massive medical breakthroughs so I have
chosen a path in life that I know
guarantees me a certain regret and so
how does one deal with that and is it
the wise choice that's the the magnitude
of the regret though is is where I feel
like there could be you know cuz you I'm
I'm sure you've read stumbling on
happiness right uh maybe so his whole
thing is that like we don't know what
happiness is our brain is a prediction
engine and we think we can accurately
predict how we will feel in the future
but the truth is you have no idea
absolutely no idea and I'm wondering if
maybe like you know come 65 come 80
whatever like you think you'll have
guilt you think you'll have uh regret
but it could be a different level of it
Beast yeah something that I don't see
coming let me ask one I have to
acknowledge that that is a possibility
okay so again we are all making
decisions with imperfect information but
let me ask you if I brought my dog down
right now and I sat her next to you
would You Weep openly for your lack of
sense of smell how do you go through
life imagine my dog this I'm not making
this up my dog can smell if one of her
favorite humans was here a day ago and
what mood they were in you can't
do you feel any sense of
deficit I don't feel any sense of
deficit from not having a kid now it's
entirely possible that if I suddenly had
that sense of smell and then lost it
that I would weep for the loss of that
sense of smell because my brain now
understands what it is that I'm missing
but for better or worse because I have
big brothered at a level most people
will never do and I
was very involved very inv involved with
a kid from 8 to uh
16ish very involved I got a taste of
what it's like to be a parent to love
somebody just irrationally to have them
love you back um and I'm talking to the
point where this kid begged is the right
word to me to basically become his
father and to take him in and let him
live with me and so we were very close
and I was like oh wow I get now the
realities of this and as any parent will
tell you it is uh big brothering for
somebody is a small fraction of what you
experience when it's your own child that
that is the first thing they will tell
you so I get that but they will also
tell you that it's a very complicated
thing and that it isn't all upside that
there is some pretty big downsides it
has a very big impact on your life and
so I've tasted it enough to know having
kids would be amazing if I did it it
would clearly manipulate my brain
chemistry to the point where I would say
this is the most profound thing that
I've ever done I can't believe I waited
this long what was I thinking to not
have kids right but without doing it I
don't have that sense without doing it
I'm like in fact I'll I'll ask parents
again thank you for your service and I
say this not to challenge your decision
I say it so people can understand mine
what if I told you that not having kids
would deepen your relationship with your
significant other to truly share a life
with someone
and to build things in this world is
unimaginably gratifying and that I have
a prediction I don't know that this is
true but I have a prediction that
marriages without kids are happier than
marriages with kids now Studies have
been done and kids for sure diminish
your overall uh life satisfaction there
are other things that go up and I forget
the exact curve and it might come back
like when you're in your 60s but from
like the time you have your kid until
after all of them have left the house
for a significant period of time it
diminishes your overall sense of
well-being so having kids is is an act
the ultimate Act of sacrifice it's
beautiful it's wonderful amazing and I
hope people do it I think it is the most
obvious life path to go down if you want
to be fulfilled I just want to be so
clear about that but there is another
side to that coin and it's pretty bright
and sunny over on my side of the road so
now having said all that I can think
nothing worse literally nothing than
losing a child because of what it would
do I get that like everything would
shift in my brain and I'd be like I
can't believe I didn't do this sooner um
and that's why the death of a child even
to somebody like me who does not have
kids that is clearly the most horrifying
thing a person can go through Ben
Shapiro we had him on the show he has a
quote he loves saying which is like
humans experience emotion on a scale of
like 0 to 10 um and then you get married
then your emotion goes from1 to 20 right
something bad happen happens to your
wife you feel more intensely than you
ever felt before when you were single
then you have kids and you remove those
ranges entirely I mean it's just
negative Infinity to infinity and I also
think that there's like a sense of
beauty and fulfillment that can come
from experiencing something even if it's
negative so deeply because I feel like
it can transform you more spur action
more and in the long term be more
fulfilling changing than any other thing
agreed this is why I think most people
should have kids thought it through very
very are you
sure well so remember I want to have
kids I just want to not have kids more
than I want to have kids so no one has
to convince me that that would be a
beautiful life path or that I have
missed something in in not choosing that
I have uh I refer to it as a mental
illness I don't mean that to be flippant
I mean but th this is how problematic
this is in my life there is one true
fact about being a human that bothers me
so much it has caused most of the
suffering and failure in my life and
that is you can be anything you want in
life but not everything and so I can't
both be a parent and not a parent I have
to pick a path now I've obviously chosen
my path uh and that will have
consequences being a parent has
consequences right what whatever life
path you choose you're not going to get
to run the control and say what would my
life have been had I not or what would
my life been if I did so you just have
to pick your path and then the important
thing is you have to have the
psychological defenses against when
you're 80 and you're like oh my God I'm
going to die and there's going to be
nothing of me to leave Beyond and I am
well aware that look impact theory for
as many views as we've gotten and for as
many people as we'll Discover it
hopefully after I die man that will
be here today and gone tomorrow like
there will be another person long before
I'm dead and gone that replaces me my
audience dies whatever like I don't
think in terms of what what are things
Beyond me I think only how will I feel
While I'm Alive about the fact that
there will be nothing that lives beyond
me and I know there's such a huge
evolutionary push at my back to make
sure that I care about that that that is
going to be a problem so I need to have
mental defenses so my wife and I already
talked about this and what are going to
be the things that we do to have next
Generation people in our lives as we get
older where we're able to impart some of
the wisdom that we've gleaned which will
make us feel good I'm sure will
completely reduce the scale I doubt be
on YouTube at 80 who knows play this
clip you know in in whatever 30 years um
but yeah I doubt that that's how that
will play out I think I will be like a a
light switch that one day has turned off
and I don't worry about it anymore and
it's only what I think now question for
you since you put your wife ahead of
your business if she came to you and
says I changed my mind today let's have
kids would you be a th% on board that
would be a very serious conversation
because we would go back to this is
really going to make your audience hate
me uh so the conversation that my wife
and I had went like this hey I'm fully
here for it if you want to have kids
let's have kids I'm ready but I want to
be clear about what I want from my life
I want to build companies and that means
I'm not going to be the one getting up
in the middle of the night I will hire
you a Night Nurse I don't expect you to
do anything I'm not prepared to do I'm
more than happy to earn enough money
that that we can do that and at the time
I said this we had enough money that I
could do that and so I was like you
sleep through the night too cool I'm I'm
here for it but I'm not going to be
changing diaper I'm not going to be
getting up in the middle of the night
I'm going to be building the business
I'm not going to be home every night at
5 or 6 for dinner if you're cool with
that then I'm ready no problem I would
never ask you not to have children as a
mother I have to imagine as a father it
feels like it would be easier that
there's less evolutionary pressure at my
back than there would be for a woman so
it's like if you want kids
1,000% now if she was like I want you to
stop running companies and I want to
have a kid and like I want you to be
here at 5:00 every night I'd be like o
we are now misaligned and let's look at
how we find something that we're both
going to be happy with now I have
learned one immutable truth life is all
about compromise I want my wife to be
happy and so we would find a path we
have with every difficult problem we
have ever faced including my wife going
from housewife to entrepreneur which if
you want to do something hard try that
uh that that was certainly not an easy
path to walk and we found uh the other
side like it might be that if I had kids
like it would just end up being way
better
a% but can we admit that there's also a
possibility that it just doesn't end up
suiting me and it ends up being
something where I'm like man kind of
bummed that I had kids and now I can't
take it back and so just like in
business I'm always asking what's my out
in this contract as long as I have an
out man I'm good with kids there's no
out
adoption I mean yes we're we
got but part part of
me part of me thinks though in terms of
successful people having kids and the
kids maybe not turning out as they
should some of that I feel like is the
unhealthy Obsession that people compare
the kids with their really successful
parents and the kids cannot Forge an
identity that's of their own because
they're constantly compared to the
parent and if they don't live up to that
or exceed it then they're seen as a
failure why didn't you do that you had
all these resources and I think that
screws a lot of people yeah agreed So
and I've thought a lot about that my kid
would grow up rich as hell what do you
do about that so that was another reason
I didn't want to have kids read the
power of myth unbelievable and it talks
about coming of age rituals and how
people used to be like all right go kill
a bear or whatever some percentage of
the kids got mauled and killed by the
Bear Just that's what it is and it's
like yeah but you kind of got to do
something and so I didn't know if with
my personality I could watch my own kids
suffer and just stand back and be like
good luck I didn't trust myself to do it
now of course if I did it and I had kids
I'd find ways I'm not delusional I'm
just saying there were a lot of things
where I was like uh that doesn't sound
fun I don't know that I want to do that
so last time we had you on the podcast
you said something about relationships
that was like I seeing The Fifth
Dimension for me right so like you said
that a lot of divorces happen after it
was like 25 years and you originally
thought it was because the kid is 18
turns out it's just because the two
people have completely different worldly
views than each other because they see
life through a lens their lens gets more
obscured the more experiences they have
the more situations they've been in the
more relationships they've had Etc I
want to know what are the foundations of
a happy marriage like the things that
you should actually be focusing on
everyone says be open be honest Etc so
what are like the the most key things
and on top of that if your wife does not
look good in a dress do you tell her so
we'll start with the easy one if your
wife doesn't look good in a dress you
need to tell her yeah 100% to beon you
know markon had the same and he was so
sure of it so sure of it let me tell you
why everybody needs to be show so sure
of this when your wife is a bag of
wrinkles or she's fat while pregnant and
you look over at her and say you look so
beautiful I have never been more
attracted to you in this moment knowing
that you're caring my child like I I
just I am over come she'll believe you
because the time that she looked bad in
that dress you were like you don't look
good in that dress and that is literally
what I tell my wife when she asked me
something hard and I tell her the truth
I'm like I need you to believe me when
you're 80 and you're a bag of wrinkles
and still I look at you and I say you
are beautiful I am still attracted to
you I'm still into you that you know
it's the truth because in moments like
this where it would have been so much
easier to lie I didn't also in that
moment when I needed it to count you
knew yeah I agree with that that's
something that I've gotten a lot better
about Macy's been very upfront where she
wants me to be completely honest with
her if she asks me a question does this
look good yes or no what do you think of
this in the beginning I'll be it was
easier for me to say it's it's great
because to me it's just you know I don't
want to upset somebody yeah but I've
gotten really good at saying I don't
like it and I feel so uncomfortable
saying something like that like anything
that could be hurtful I just just crawl
up and I hate it but it's been something
that it's it's a muscle that I've been
building of just you know being
completely honest in terms of like my
opinion on something it will pay you
dividends yep so on the topic of
relationships and success for the
viewers watching maybe they have a
girlfriend maybe they have a fiance
maybe they have a wife what would you
tell them if they're trying to have the
happiest and most fulfilled relationship
which you would probably argue as one of
the most important things that you could
possibly do in your entire life
to the best extent that they could
possibly have okay so number one there's
a reason everybody says communication
but communication has to include the
definition of words so you're going to
be using words that mean different
things to each of you and it will cause
a lifetime of disconnecting so one word
that Lisa and I took the time to Define
was important so if I say this is
important to me it means I do not care
what you're doing drop it and address
this thing which means you can't say it
very often so there are when Lisa and I
get into like contentious moments is
when something is only meaningful but
it's not important so it's like I'm not
going to use the word important on this
but it is Meaningful and so now the
person's like okay well I have to weigh
it against all the things that I'm doing
and whether I'm going to drop this or
not whatever and do the thing for you
but once we established hey this is
important we had a chip basically that
we could lay at any time that said I
need you to come help me address this
whatever pay attention to this come to
my show whatever the thing is and that
was life-changing because because before
it was like the person would say oh this
is important to me you thought oh
important it means it's like you know in
your top five or six things whatever
that's how maybe the other person
defined important and it was causing all
these fights the next thing is never
argue about the tea all right what do I
mean by that the biggest fight Lisa and
I ever got into was over a cup of tea
and I'm talking screaming match man so
we were going uh on our first vacation
in like six years something ridiculous
and it was for one night and so I didn't
want to go cuz it was time away from
work I didn't want to spend the money
cuz we were so broke and but she was
like it's you know important we got to
do it so I'm like okay so we're going on
that day wake up and I'm like car's
packed ready to go at like 8:00 a.m. or
whatever I'm ready to walk out the door
so that we can get to the hotel so the
moment you know whatever 3:00 they'll
let you in the room they'll let us in
the room and I can get the most out of
my dollar to get in the room that's what
I'm thinking it's not what I say what I
say is why you having a cup of tea and
she's like oh I just want to have a cup
of tea now for her it was oh my God he's
not taking a day off in six years this
is amazing we're finally going to get to
spend some quality time I want to take
things slow and just relax and enjoy my
time and not feel like there's an agenda
and I have to be somewhere there's no
time schedule but she's not saying that
she's just saying I want to have a cup
of tea so now I'm like hold on we're
taking a day off and you're going to
have a cup of tea and she's hearing yeah
we're taking a day off so we can relax
yes I'm going to have a cup of tea and
so we're arguing arguing and finally I
get her in the car and we're still
arguing about the cup of tea cuz she's
now mad and can enjoy our cup of tea we
are driving to the vacation destination
we're yelling at each other I am so
angry and so irate that she doesn't care
about the massive sacrifice that I've
made the money that I'm wasting on the
stupid vacation and she's so annoyed
that I still even on vacation won't just
take time to spend with her with no
agenda and nowhere to be of course none
of this is being said we're just arguing
about the cup of tea I turned the car
around on the freeway and I'm like we
are going home this is going to be a
waste of time and as I turned turn the
car around there is a voice in my head
screaming there is no way this is about
a cup of tea so what the hell is
actually happening and in that moment I
learned one of the most important
relationship uh pieces of advice that I
have for people and that is speak in
insecurities and so as I turned the car
around I
said I'm afraid that I will never make
good on my promise to make you rich and
I told your dad that when he thought I
was going to fail and make you poor
which so far is all I have done you are
at home clipping coupons I'm getting
emotional now remembering what it was
like to be in that phase you're at home
clipping coupons you would have been
better off staying with your dad and so
for me to take a day off is terrifying
to not be working right now is the
scariest thing I can think of and the
only way that I can justify it is if we
maximize every dollar and so we are
literally standing at the check-in
counter when they say you can now go and
your room so that the room I'm paying
for were able to get every minute of use
out of that and she was like w she was
like I'm afraid that I'm losing you to
work and that I never see you and that
we never spend quality time together
anymore and now all the sudden we're
actually saying the truth we're saying
the thing that neither of us were not
even like I realized I needed to
articulate this out loud I just had all
of this baggage my value system my
beliefs my fears were all there
and I just reacted to the cup of tea and
I didn't know yet at the time not to
distrust my emotions I felt the thing
that thing had to be right so I reacted
she felt the thing she had to be right
so she just reacted so now we have a
rule in our relationship if one of us is
angry guaranteed an insecurity has been
triggered so the person who can the most
quickly identify what the insecurity is
and just name it wins because you'll
diffuse the argument because if you
really love each other and the person's
like yo this is where I'm coming from
it's ugly I need to work on it my
insecurities are mine to deal with you
should not just have to Forever deal
with my insecurities but I'm going to
say it out loud and name it so that I
can improve upon it and in this moment
I'm just asking for a bit of Grace as I
process through this and deal with this
thing and then you have to reciprocate
that you never and I mean never
weaponize somebody's insecurities
against them because in my marriage my
wife knows how to destroy me destroy me
she knows every insecurity that I have
exactly where they're located how to
press right on them and just completely
destroy me cuz I've given myself over to
her and said something akin to As Long
As You Love Me I can lose everything
else not something akin to that I've
said those exact words as long as you
love me that I'm good and so I can lose
all my money everyone can think I'm an
but if I've made you proud if
I've protected you and made you feel
loved and made you feel like my number
one I've won and I can exist in a world
where we have nothing but each other and
that is terrifying comforting so that
means that even though I could end every
single argument we ever have by just
going hey you're doing that thing that
you've already admitted that you suck at
or whatever and don't bring that
up shut your mouth because you know
insecurity over here and you know you're
bad at this you're not thinking right
and it would end the argument and it
would also end my marriage and so never
ever ever weaponizing your insecurities
against that person even when it means
you could get the upper hand you could
win the argument whatever whatever you
just can't ever ever it when you're
elevating that person and they
legitimately feel better about
themselves when they're around you than
when they don't or when they're not it
that's a magical place but you really do
have to be very protective of that
bubble and then something that not
nearly enough people think about you got
to have sex a lot otherwise I mean
depends on your age honestly poor my
poor wife uh when we were in our 20s two
a day was my like go-to ask for poor
wife my poor wife because that her
number was not to a day I'll just say
that uh and over time it definitely
becomes a far more reasonable number uh
but you should be having sex weekly for
sure maybe multiple times a week even as
you get into your 40s and 50s I'll
report back on 60s uh when when I get
there but your hormones do change
there's no doubt about that so it
becomes different but you do not want to
become roommates how do you recognize
your own insecurity
cuz I try to think like what are things
that people could say to me that would
really really hurt me and to be honest I
don't know if it's certain things rather
than certain people because I have
certain people that I have very close to
me like my parents my best friend my
brother
Etc and they can say things but it's not
the fact that they're saying this exact
thing that pushes that button in me it's
just the fact that it's someone that I
really admire someone that I have hold
to high esteem and if they say something
critical of me that I think is very Fair
obviously it's going to hurt me you know
so how do you recognize like really what
you're insecure about or do you have
those insecurities they're just so far
hidden well so there's two really
interesting questions in there one how
do you recognize your insecurities I
think everybody recognizes their
insecurities because there's a bodily
response to it now whether they
recognize what triggers the insecurity
is a totally different question oh I'm
worried that so for instance I once got
in a big fight with my then
fiance uh on a game of pool and and we
were playing a game of pool and I was
winning and it came to the eightball and
I had the shot perfect and she came up
and whispered something really sexy in
my ear but it made me miss the shot and
she ended up winning the game and I was
really pissed and I remember thinking
wait a second I can either take
advantage of that sexy thing that she
whispered in my ear and have one kind of
night or I can be pissed that I lost
this pool match and have a totally
different kind of night that is way less
fun and I was like why am I going with
the fighting over the losing the game
and then I realized oh my God I have a
base assumption that if I'm not better
than her at everything she won't find me
sexually attractive and then I was like
that is really stupid because who on
God's green earth would want to be in a
relationship with somebody who's better
than them at everything every time you
turn around you are the Lesser person
people want to be needed they want to be
like your partner your equal now
hopefully you're good at different
things because then you both get your
opportunities to shine that was a huge
breakthrough for me so but that took me
a minute to understand oh I got pissed
because I'm insecure about this thing
over here so now I may be unusually good
about relatively quickly identifying
what is that cause because I made myself
a promise a long time ago I'd never lie
to myself I may lie to other people not
saying I don't lie to other people but I
don't lie to myself and so if the answer
is oh you think she won't be sexually
attracted to you unless you're better
than her at everything I'm like wow
that's really icky and that's like so
weak-minded
so that allows me to then deal with it
because I'm willing to face it uh but
for people that have a harder time with
that journal and you want to be able to
any belief you have you should be able
to write in a single sentence with no
commas parentheticals just like a single
clean sentence I feel this way because
boom and until when you write that
single short sentence it feels like a
puzzle piece clicking into place you
have not figured it out and just keep
journaling there are times I've
journaled on some ideas for like 25,000
words that's basically a noela and it
will just for whatever reason that idea
is complicated and I can't untangle it
not to get it into something simple I
could probably explain it in a paragraph
but that means you don't understand it
well enough yet how do you start
journaling and this is something that
you have to physically write down or are
we talking like you could just be a
keyboard how do you start keyboard's
fine I use a keyboard um and I would
literally often times my journal entry
starts with uh HHH H HH dot dot dot
where I'm just like uh I think and so
whatever is in my mind I type and
there's something about the
synchronicity of having to think it and
type it that slows my brain down enough
and forces me to actually take it from
the emotional right which is that
subconscious communication and forces me
to pull it through that narrow bandwidth
of words to be able to actually get a
hold of the idea in in a conscious way
where I can now manipulate it in my
conscious control I have just found that
journaling is one of the most insanely
useful things but you can also Journal
verbally I think this is why a lot of
people like to talk like I just need to
talk it out and so my wife and I will do
that and we ask and this is hey another
marriage tip here that is very common
knowledge but so few people do it at the
beginning of a conversation my wife and
I will say do you want me to just listen
or do you want me to offer Solutions
guys just want to give Solutions it
drives me crazy ter my wife wor that I
feel I feel your pain I feel it makes
sense to want to fix it correct what's
the point of talking about if if if
you're not going to if you just if you
just hear it out it also sometimes
solves it you know no but the solutions
if you're like 2 plus two could be this
and I'm like it's four it's four this is
but also isn't it more powerful in the
long term for them to figure it out on
their own they're building up a muscle
they're get but if we're not working
towards a solution if it's like 2 plus
two just a CR that they lean on at that
point but but it could be working on a
solution together verus just hearing
it's you feeding the solution no for me
it's like 2 plus two could be this but
like you know I don't say that but I'm
just saying like hypothetically it could
be not working towards a solution but
just like you know talking are we
talking about this or are we talking
about something else right now I don't
know what we're talking we got to talk
about the team man fair I will say that
you both have extremely important points
so you do need to let the person talk so
they can figure it out on their own
because they're effectively journaling
out loud and you need to give them the
space to work through the ideas uh and
then the other side is is that if they
really aren't trying to work towards a
solution like if they're not trying to
come to understand it so they can do
something about it then it's fruitless
and you're going to death Loop and so my
wife and I have you know I mean an
intuitive sense of when to pull that
card but we'll say to the other person
you're death looping so it's like this
isn't now about understanding you've
already repeated that you understand it
you're still not doing anything about it
so now let's talk about that because
there is a point at which like it's just
too frustrating to sit here and like go
through the same thing again and again
and again
but I would say for the health the
emotional health of each person you do
want to give them a pretty large leeway
to think through that problem how does
it not seem insensitive when you say
you're death looping uh well this is
where how do you balance the two like I
want to listen to you versus like and
she's like no I'm not death looping I'm
not you just you know there might be
times where I see the emotional state
that she's in and I'm like hey you're
looping around this idea and you know is
there you think there's anything else
you might be struggling with or that
might be bothering you and then there
are going to be other times I'm like hey
you are now death looping so you really
have to be sensitive man and this is
same thing with being an entrepreneur
like there are so many things that
people actually have to understand and
this is why I worry a little bit about
the age of um of YouTube and
Entrepreneurship so I used to offer a
course called business decision making
worst title for a course ever but
actually the only course that people
need and the point of the course was to
teach people how to solve novel problems
s which is what an entrepreneur is but
if you want to make a lot of money sell
a course on how to Market or get leads
or whatever because that's what people
think they need but the reality is your
business will not last long if you can't
solve novel problems getting into like
the the rats nest of all the Nuance of
all the factors that come together that
really is the only way and so the only
way to get through some of this stuff is
just a ton of repetition so that you
start to understand the Nuance of this
situation that person in this particular
emotional state it all has to come
together for you to know exactly how to
play that given moment is it difficult
for you to place 100% trust in another
person not really not if you do it in
increments so take Lisa and I one you
have to be a good judge of character two
you have to spend time with them in
order to better understand what they're
like uh three you have to understand
that of course there are going to be
things you're blindsided by so you know
what human nature is you know that
people are capable of lying and so what
you have to trust is that have I done
enough due diligence to really
understand who this person is at their
core have I seen them at you know in
different situations have I seen them
under duress um if you know we've been
together long enough so even I didn't
even tell Lisa that I loved her until
we'd been together for I don't know had
to be close to three months and so and
then like where I was like I fully trust
you I mean you're looking at a year two
years I mean like like you know it isn't
it isn't binary I don't trust you at all
I'm keeping you at arms length it's like
hey you know um an insecurity of mine do
you ever use it against me oh wow no
they haven't you come up with agreements
about like the word important do they
show up when you use the word important
um you agree that you're not going to
abuse the word important it's the kind
of thing you should only use a few times
a year are they using it a few times a
week you have all these things it's when
people trust their emotion that they get
themselves into trouble but distrust my
emotions so if I'm like oh my God this
person's amazing I bet I could just like
give my entire life over to them it's
like well that's the feeling but I
haven't seen them in enough scenarios
and so I think it was Reagan that said
trust but verify so you do need to
extend some trust otherwise if you're
constantly like I don't trust you and
closing people out they're never going
to reciprocate and you're going to end
up in this sort of you're constantly
pushing each other back stance and I
don't think you're going to get where
you need to go doing that what are some
some arguments that you feel like every
couple should go through to learn about
the other person I think of an argument
as something that's contentious I don't
know that it needs to be contentious now
contentiousness may arise from being
very pointed blunt I would say what I
call being aggressively myself so there
the number of times I've been in an
argument whether in business or in my
relationship where I'm like I can end
this argument right now and I will say
these words out loud I could end this
argument right now you've extended the
olive branch but the reality is that
isn't how I feel and you're
misunderstanding my position so my
position is actually this which then
will reopen the argument and an argument
that you could have swept under the rug
and been done with in 20 minutes may now
go on for two hours 3 hours whatever but
it is what it is you have to get to the
point where you can steal man each
other's argument and say either oo I I
understand you and now I agree or I
understand you and will articulate your
position so well that you will say the
words back to me you understand my
position perfectly and so that's what Le
leis and I will do I'll make my team
here at impact Theory do the same here's
how I see your position do I understand
it perfectly and they'll say yes no no
no say the words you understand my
position perfectly you understand my
position perfectly okay cool so now as
we continue this debate you know it's
not because I don't understand so don't
come at me again saying no no you're
just not understanding something you've
agreed I understand your position
perfectly so now what we have is a
difference in values it's not that I
don't understand you so now we're having
a collision of values and how do we
navigate a collision of values and going
back to relationship of any kind you
need to have rules of engagement around
how you navigate a collision of values
and if you can both articulate the other
side so well that you'll each say yes
you understand my position perfectly now
you're just like okay I understand you
you understand me neither of us are
going to yield on our value system so
how are we going to deal with this and
then you just come up with whatever you
think is reasonable for dealing with
that but often times a collision of
values ends a relationship and how do
you find a compromise in a situation
like that depends on how badly you want
to stay together so uh with leis and I
there's one thing we we legitimately
can't get to the other side of and this
is because it isn't important enough and
we both feel violently that the other
person is wrong so I believe that life
is really about becoming efficient and
so as I'm walking towards a car door I
want to make sure that I have the key
fob out and I press the button right so
that it beeps as my hand grabs it and I
can sit in there's not not even a half
second pause anywhere your face tells me
you get it I do everything in life like
that and to me there are huge
consequences my success in life think is
largely due to my just absolutely
Relentless obsession with efficiency
getting things done as quickly as you
can in as few movements as possible so
in life though Lisa likes things to be
tidy so she likes things to be put away
which is anathema to being efficient
because now I don't know where things
are and to make things worse my wife
doesn't believe in putting things in
their place so like you go in a workshop
and it's got every tool outlined and so
you know exactly where it goes I could
get behind that no she just needs it to
be away out of sight so you open a
cupboard and everything's a mess
but it's in the cupboard that drives me
bananas now she can articulate my side
of it to where you would think she's
going to be like yeah yeah yeah that is
better and I can articulate her side
which has to do with how she was raised
and anxiety about things not being tidy
y y and you would think I'd be so
empathetic that I'd be like okay I get
it when in reality we're both like this
is dumb the way you do it does not make
any sense all things considered and so
we've had to come up with compromises
cuz it's not important I'm not going to
blow my marriage up over that so it's
like we come up with rules and things
like that and we deal with it this might
be too personal is there anything that
you would be willing to blow up the
marriage for I love this I love to
future interviewers I love when people
ask me questions we're like should I ask
this I don't know those are more fun uh
if you if anybody ever asked something
that I don't want to answer I will not
be offended I'll say I'm not going to
answer that but this one's great so what
would I blow my marriage up over uh so
if my wife cheated on me that is you
will not find Tom being like we
reconciled yeah uh that that is a
betrayal that I am not interested in
trying to work my way back from that's
really the only thing I was once asked
if Lisa hit me because her hers is
cheating and beating if I cheat on her
or beat her done finished there's no
coming back and trust me my wife is so
stubborn she means the great news is I
have no interest in either of those but
for me I was asked once if she hit you
would you um end the relationship and
the answer is no because I'm not
physically afraid of her so it wouldn't
trigger a Cascade of things that I would
worry about so for people who
legitimately have reasons to be afraid
of their significant other uh I get it
totally understand that is not a
judgment on anybody but uh that's my
stance that's the only thing if she
weaponized an insecurity against me that
would be that would put us in very
dangerous territory and so that I would
say like I get it people make missteps
but I would like to point out that that
was you just weaponized my insecurity
against me for the first time in
whatever 21 years of marriage we'd
really have to sit down and talk about
how did we get here what made you do
that how do I know that you're not going
to do that in the future because that is
going to make me hesitant and I wouldn't
be in a marriage where I can't give
myself over completely to the person
there's just too many sacrifices in a
marriage to make that work that'd be the
only thing that I'd really be worried
about um if we ended up having if she
wanted me to give up my ambition that
would be another one that was one I told
her when we first got engaged was like
you can ask me to give up anything
except my ambition I don't know who I am
am without it and I don't want to know
who I would be without it what are your
biggest insecurities if you're
comfortable to say what are my biggest
insecurity and God people in my audience
are just going to be sick of hearing me
say this but it's the honest truth my
biggest insecurity is that I'm not smart
enough to accomplish the things that I
want to accomplish and that sounds easy
enough to say but it it really messes
with me what do you think it is about
that that messes with you so much
because is it your identity is at risk
of you just being the one who's like I'm
Tom I did all of this it's tied to that
the growth mindset will save you from
virtually everything because what it
says is hey just because you failed at
that thing and you're a loser right now
doesn't mean you have to be a loser
tomorrow or even later tonight right you
can get a better skill and then perform
better and have the impact on the world
that you want to have if the lesson life
teaches me is that I run out of
potential before I run out of
time that's rough that's like playing a
game that you know you're going to lose
and so then and look I can already see
the defense mechanisms I would put in
plays like hey to be the kind of person
I want to be I'll play my guts out even
though I know I'm going to lose okay
cool and I would shift my thinking over
to that so I have defenses against the
dark arts but yeah that really will be
disappointing I just that would be
disappointing if I'm not able to
accomplish the things that I set out to
accomplish because I have a a limited um
what do they call it g Factor that'll be
sad is G Factor just like a raw
intelligence type thing okay because you
also said that like you think
accomplishments are 50% effort 50% like
intelligence so you're referring to that
other 50% of just like the innate yeah I
don't know if I've ever said it that way
the way I would normally say it is
you're 50% malleable and you're 50%
hardwired so we are not blank SLS which
um I think there is some confusion about
in society at large these days you you
cannot turn anybody into anything just
biology is real and so accepting that
part of my biology is my level of
intelligence it's like I've been able to
do a lot with the intelligence that I
have and so that's pretty cool but when
I try to grasp Concepts that um somebody
like Einstein seemed to grasp pretty
easily I'm just like Jesus do you think
that insecurity is serving you or do you
think it would be better if you
conquered it it's a good question I
don't know so I get some like I have
enough of an a fear that I'll never be
enough that it pushes me really really
hard and certainly the world has gotten
things out of me that they wouldn't have
gotten out of if I was just like yeah no
I'm totally good with who I am this is
all good I don't need to get better I
don't have anything to prove I think
like secretly this is why I say I don't
think the goal should be to get rid of
the negative voice I think the evolution
is pretty brilliant and has been like no
you need to feel like you have something
to prove in order to get you to go
conquer the very terrifying and very
dangerous world around you um so I think
that insecurity probably serves us all
what do you think is the biggest problem
with Humanity today or Society whoa keep
it brief by the way 30 seconds okay um
people don't distrust themselves enough
I kind of agree with you and that's what
stumbling on happiness the book I just
referenced is a lot about people have
way too much confidence in themselves
minds are brains are developed to
recognize patterns to positively affirm
itself it's always going to be biased
and you're going to think that you're
God everyone has a bit of narcissism
narcissism everyone has it and I I
completely agree with you yeah preach
brother preach let's get some book
recommendations for those listening that
want to expand their minds which books
would you recommend okay so I have a
reading list people should check out
it's free uh mindset is the most
important book in the English language
if you have not already adopted truly a
growth mindset you you are going to fail
extreme ownership by Jaco willink I
think is just massively important people
really need to understand that obstacle
his way by Ryan holiday another Banger
if you want to understand how you fail
your way to success those three will get
people started and then if you're an
entrepreneur you need to read Elon
musk's biography by Walter Isaacson not
because I think it's going to make you
like him it may make you dislike him but
you're going to understand George
Bernard Shaw's quote about all progress
depending on the unreasonable man why do
you think we exist here what do you
think is the meaning of this I don't
think there is any meaning other than
what you ascribe to it I think you are
the result of of rules of physics that
got set in motion Maybe by a 12-year-old
doing a science experiment on a
supercomputer somewhere in the future uh
but nonetheless there are just laws put
in motion and we are the result how
confident are you in that of that I am
more confident than anything else that
I've encountered in life but strong
convictions loosely held if I get
information to the contrary tomorrow
word remember I am trying to get to
ground truth it when I act as if I'm
they're just a bunch of physical rules
and as long as I adhere to those I move
forward towards my goals when I act like
that I actually move forward towards my
goals every time I act in any other way
someone else is going to come and save
me there's um you know a benevolent
being that has my best interest at heart
I don't move where I want to go or I can
manifest something do you feel like it
helps people to have a higher power yes
I think there are tremendous reasons to
believe in a higher power in terms of
emotional wellbeing but in terms of
building your company not so much are
there certain things that you identify
with that you don't think you'd be able
to accept the truth if it were otherwise
no I don't see anything that serves me
to if if it is true there's nothing
anything that diminishes your sense of
self that's the only thing where it's
like okay you're probably still going to
get because you're likely to react
overly negative to it for the average
person like for instance if you could
just say to me Tom look supercomputer
said you really aren't smart enough to
do what you're trying to do now what you
do with that information that'd be tough
because I'd be better off to take that
advice and go okay cool I need to scale
back my ideas I don't know you've got me
at the edge of what I've thought through
so if somebody handed me like for real
for real bro you are not smart enough to
do the thing that you're trying to do it
would be wise for me to pick a slightly
different path or to find a partner
where I could like
offer assistance to the thing so I could
still be around the thing that I love
and contribute in the way that I'm truly
capable of doing
but I wouldn't want it to damage my
sense of self such that I don't keep
striving because I I live in great fear
that I never maximize my abilities so in
that case it would be better for you not
to know maybe I don't know because if if
I were going to implode at the knowledge
which is an emotional problem and not a
truth problem then yes it'd be better
that I didn't know but if I can take
that knowledge and and say okay cool I
never valued myself for the success
anyway I value myself for the sincere
Pursuit I shouldn't need to be number
one if I need to slot in behind somebody
else and be a part of their Vision
because they really are smart enough but
I can contribute and like just be a
killer here for this I should be able to
deal with that emotionally and it means
that I will actually get more towards my
goals so I'd be confronted with is this
about feeling like you're cool or is
this actually about achieving your goal
if it's actually about achieving your
goal then you need to shift what you're
building your self-esteem around so I
would like to think even in that I would
truly be better off because I believe in
myself that I could adjust to that
emotional reality but it's tough It's
it's like would I want to know that I
have Huntington's disease nothing you
can do about it so you're just going to
have to deal but I think I would want to
know because there are things I can do
lifestyle wise to at least push it off
for the average person for most people
out there do you think that they should
shift their value system to point
towards realism or do you think that
they should shift it to point towards
beliefs that they have that serve them
that aren't necessarily objectively true
like a blissful sort of ignorance well I
would never say cultivate Blissful
ignorance but I have a rule that you
should only do and believe that which
moves you towards your goals now the
reality is the truth is almost always
the thing that's going to move you
towards your goals so you really do want
to get close to ground truth again
you're just trying to get to I can
predict the outcome of my actions um so
yes I I do not overemphasize hey go find
out what is true I emphasize go figure
out what's useful um but blinding
yourself to the truth is almost
certainly a rapid path to failure Tom
thank you so much for on the iced coffee
Hour part two guys part part one link
down below your channel link down below
and uh I mean I could talk to you for
like 12 hours I want to do this for like
6 hours and just and just like we could
have dinner here we just keep talking
anytime gentlemen is anything you guys
are fun as hell is there anything that
you want to mention to our audience
anything you have coming up anything you
want to uh well hey the thing that I'm
not known for but spend an inordinate
amount of my time on is a video game
we're building called project kaisen
check that out uh I am freakishly proud
of what it's becoming and it is the game
environment where you get to pursue
empowerment so come check us out please
check it out guys link down below thank
you everyone for watching and until next
time thank you love that thank you guys
this is
something